this program is brought to you by Emory
University hi my name is Carlton
McClendon and I will be your point of
contact for all matters related to
transfer student academic advising we're
all very excited that you have chosen
Emory to continue your college career
right now there is a dedicated team of
academic advisors who are planning for
your arrival there are two very
important dates that I need to make you
aware of general orientation will take
place Saturday August 20th in the
Woodruff pé Center mandatory transfer
orientation will take place the
following day Sunday August 21st you
will receive an email later this summer
with the time and location of the
mandatory transfer orientation to enroll
in classes simply log into blackboard
and complete the transfer orientation
blackboard course once you have
completed the blackboard transfer
orientation course you will be given
instructions on how to schedule a phone
appointment with an advisor the advisor
will answer your questions and help you
enroll in classes once again welcome to
Emory and we look forward to seeing you
in August the preceding program is
copyrighted by Emory University